is another fun fall event you can't miss
this the 49th annual Greek Food Festival
this is a blast it's been going on for
years and each year gets bigger and
bigger it is a family affair we have
with us Gus Eleni and Amalia with all
the details Gus you've been overseeing
this for quite a while yeah a lot of
years probably about 15 or 16. I just
wanted to let y'all know we get bitter
and bigger and better every year well
and according to your daughters as well
because you used to oversee the kids
play area the youth area right part of
the yes and they're telling me just
before we go on it was lame yes so what
you do when they tell you that you put
them in charge there you go and so now
you guys are responsible for this Eleni
what what is that part we know about the
food and we're going to talk about that
but what is there for kids um the kids
area there's a lot of like inflatables
for younger kids and then there's also
like
um
there's rock climbing and bungee jumping
for older kids and there's also a VR set
that we just got out there and there's
going to be four of them so people can
definitely like walk around and do that
so much fun Emily you're going to be
helping out with that as well right all
right guys how did you get involved in
this and then how has it grown over the
last 15 or so years well I got involved
with it because I got roped into it but
that's that's the way it always goes but
it's just grown over the years we've
really tweaked it every year we try to
keep the same formula and improve on it
make it better it is really an
outstanding event when you come out
there there's so much energy there's
lights lasers and dancing under the
stars the smell the food cooking all the
different foods that we have people
having a great time and uh you just
can't really describe it it is a Foodies
Paradise you have just a small sampling
of of some of the stuff here tell us
what we got in front of us this is a
very small sampling but we got several
things here we got the collodia cookies
a lot of folks know those it's a it's
kind of a vanilla lemon twist to it this
is the current vietes that's the
powdered cookies these are called D plus
and this is what everybody knows about
baklava and this is something that's
really big in Greece right now this
chocolate custard cake so we're uh
offering it now but to give you an idea
we go through probably 95 000 pieces of
pastry out there over the three days so
this is a small sampling we've got so
many other different varieties out there
like my favorites bagatza it's a phyllo
dough with Custard in it and so there's
so many other pastries available like I
said this is a very small salad it is
tremendous Amalia as we get out of here
you have a favorite among these my
favorite's definitely The Baklava yeah
the winner all right tell us uh before
we leave where can people find this okay
we're located on Hacienda between Torrey
Pines and Jones you can't miss us we're
the only Byzantine structure on the
street if you're coming to the Festival
park anywhere you can on Hacienda don't
try to go right up next to church we got
shuttle buses going all the way up and
down Hacienda you can park anywhere in
Hacienda between Decatur and rainbow so
there's plenty of parking ride the
shuttle and don't sit there and have to
wait in traffic love it and you can go
to our website or yours and get more
from thank you guys so much well thank
you beautiful family too all right we
are live